[Música]
revisión de las noticias de economía con
Daniela Blandón Daniela vamos a hacer el
repaso de lo que ha acontecido más
importante hasta esta hora y vamos a
empezar con Estados Unidos que subió el
precio de sus visas si Ángela Pues el
departamento de estado anunció que a
partir del 30 de mayo de este año va a
actualizar esas tarifas para las
solicitudes de visa de no inmigrante
también para la tarjeta de cruce
fronterizo de ciudadanos mexicanos
mayores de 15 años por ejemplo el precio
de las visas de visitante de negocios o
de turismo es decir las categorías B1 y
b2 así como las de estudiantes de
intercambio van a pasar de 160 a 185
dólares entre tanto las de trabajadores
temporales ahora costarán 205 dólares y
la categoría para comerciantes de
tratados para inversionistas y para
otras ocupaciones especializadas es la
que más va a aumentar en total va a
costar 315 dólares el argumento del
gobierno es que estos precios no se
actualizaban hace aproximadamente una
dependiendo del caso bueno y por otro
lado el senado de Estados Unidos
Investiga la supuesta complejidad del
Credit suites con evasión de impuestos
millonarios Pues los primeros resultados
de una investigación del comité de
finanzas del senado dicen que se
identificaron 23 grandes cuentas en
Credit suites que no declararon
impuestos y que pertenecen a
estadounidenses ultrarricos cada uno con
activos de más de 20 millones de dólares
la investigación va más allá y señala
que empleados del segundo banco más
grande de Suiza que está recordemos en
proceso de adquisición por parte de su
rival y hubiese ayudaron voluntariamente
Adam horsey quien es un ex profesor
universitario condenado por fraude
fiscal le ayudaron o le habrían ayudado
mejor a ocultar una fortuna por 220
millones de dólares ante las autoridades
para no pagar impuestos sobre esta
fortuna entre tanto la Fed rinde hoy por
segundo día cuentas al congreso por
turbulencia bancaria pues el martes ya
había tenido lugar en la primera de lo
que se espera que sean varias audiencias
sobre el caos en los mercados hoy el
turno es para el comité de servicios
financieros de la cámara que va a
interrogar a los reguladores sobre qué
salió mal con silicon y con Signal Bank
el resumen de la jornada del martes es
muy sencillo los legisladores de ambos
partidos estuvieron de acuerdo con la
reserva Federal en que los bancos
estaban mal administrados Eso no es un
secreto sin embargo muchos cuestionaron
que la Fed no hubiera visto las señales
de advertencia para identificar y
abordar los problemas que venían desde
hace meses escuchemos
durante este periodo tal vez durante
seis meses o durante todo el año
anterior el banco estuvo sin un oficial
de gestión de riesgos es correcto
eso es lo que entiendo obviamente creo
que es una gestión terrible no tener un
director de riesgos en la empresa
el problema eran esos ejecutivos
arrogantes pero siempre serán ejecutivos
arrogantes Ese es exactamente la razón
por la necesitamos reglas estrictas en
los servidores públicos con el coraje y
las agallas para enfrentarse a los
cabilderos bancarios y hacer cumplir
Esas reglas Ángeles ya la Casa Blanca
está preparando nuevas medidas el
presidente Joe biden anticipó que la
intervención no está terminada que auto
Todavía falta mucho por hacer en este
caso veremos qué sucede por ese lado y
vamos a cambiar Mientras tanto de tema
onda llamó a revisión a más de 300
vehículos y esto pues preocupa No claro
concretamente 330 mil vehículos de onda
que deberán ser devueltos a los
concesionarios esto debido a que las
almohadillas térmicas ubicadas detrás de
los espejos retrovisores pueden no estar
unidas correctamente según el órgano de
vigilancia de Estados Unidos esto podría
provocar que el vidrio del espejo se
caiga y esto aumenta desde luego el
riesgo de un accidente los modelos
incluidos son el 11 2020 a 2022 el de
2020 a 2022 el piloto de 2020 a 2021 y
el online de 2020 a 2021 la
administración nacional de seguridad del
tráfico en carreteras también abrió una
nueva investigación contra tesla por
quejas de consumidores sobre el mal
funcionamiento de los cinturones de
seguridad específicamente en los modelos
x del 2022 y 2023 normalmente estas
investigaciones conducen a estos
llamados que hacen las empresas le pido
que hagamos el paso a los indicadores
las bolsas se mueven con cautela en días
de calma después de dos semanas de
turbulencia Wall Street abrió al alza
tras el alivio del estrés en el sistema
bancario que generó esta venta de los
activos del silicon de la que hablábamos
a comienzos de esta semana en Europa que
opera al alza hay noticias bursátiles
que vienen del sector aéreo de la
irlandesa Brian nerd anunció que este
año las tarifas aéreas podrían subir
entre el 10 y el 15% y La alemana luffa
danza aseguró hoy que están haciendo los
mejores márgenes de su historia Asia
cerró en positivo con el índice de Hong
Kong subiendo más del 2% . Daniela
gracias a usted que descanse que
desayune rico y nos vemos mañana Muchas
gracias Mañana nos vemos